because obviously there's the
personality that we show in our videos
right now our own personality like I
don't have to deal with it too much cuz
I feel like I'm pretty close to what I
am in real life yeah yeah but I
definitely have some friends who are
youtubers who like are very very
different to how they're perceived oh
yeah I'm sure Emily won't let me say
Emma reach you she's like a storytime
animator right very like very like this
this image of like pure right like
everyone thinks that she's like a Disney
character yeah you hang out with her
she's a normal person right I mean if
you follow on Twitter yeah yeah right
right and that's the thing right is that
I know she gets stressed out with it
more than most and she told me a few
times and she's like I wish people would
just stop treating me like a Disney
character yeah like people won't let us
say things when when she says things
like oh you know that are a little crude
me yeah she gets a lot of comments being
like this is not how you supposed to act
that's not you yeah people literally
tell her you shouldn't act this with
this is not how you're supposed to act
like and it's weird because it's like I
don't have to deal with that if I do
have the [ __ ] I want and people like
haha funny you know yeah teehee I but
like it's really creepy saying it was we
wash this thing on top yeah it was
really weird for me because I met Emily
IRL before I saw any of her YouTube
stuff so it was went me watching her
videos it was kind of a reverse shock
for that yeah wow you're so you're so
pure not to say that emily is like
crazier firstly burn more dimensional
than a Disney person yeah yeah yeah even
try and put that on herself right on
kids let's just cut how the audience
it's funny because Sydney or sits now
yeah she has like the opposite problem
where people come to me and they're like
what why Sydney acting so hyperactive
and so loud in her inner videos I'm like
the big difference between Sydney in her
videos in Sydney in real life is that
Sydney and in inner videos has a volume
button like I can physically turn her
down in when she's in a video I can't
physically turn her down you can I put
like a normalization
I'll do that